[Música]
27 aviones de guerra chinos sobrevolaron
la zona de defensa aérea de taiwán luego
de la visita de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes estadounidense
nancy pelosi china dice que es para
disuadir las acciones de estados unidos
pero taipei denuncia un bloqueo
conectamos con mexico
y ha partido desde turquía el primer
buque que llevará granos ucranianos a
líbano desde que comenzó la guerra
el barco razón y fue inspeccionado en el
puerto de estambul como parte del
acuerdo que firmaron rusia y ucrania con
la mediación de los turcos y la onu los
informaremos desde la capital del país
presentó su renuncia el presidente del
consejo de ministros de perú aníbal
torres si el mandatario pedro castillo
la acepta todos los ministros deben
enviar su división este sería el quinto
gabinete de castillo en el año que lleva
gobernando tenemos reporte desde el iva
bienvenidos a france 24 estas son las
noticias internacionales y mi nombre es
maría clara calle
comenzamos en asia pues aumentan las
tensiones entre china y taiwán por la
visita de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi ella
afirmó que su visita al territorio
autónomo que los chinos reclaman como
propio debe entenderse como un apoyo de
washington a taipei pelosi se reunió con
la presidenta taiwanesa sign in one y
hoy abandonó la isla para seguir su gira
asiática por corea del sur y japón
veamos lo que ocurrió en su recorrido
por taiwán cuando nancy pelosi se reunió
con la presidenta de taiwán sign when su
visita ya había desatado la ira de china
para beijing la isla autogobernada es
parte de su territorio y la visita de
pelosi es una forma de cuestionar su
soberanía la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu fue directa a la
hora de abordar la situación en taiwán
hoy el mundo se enfrenta a una elección
entre la democracia y la autocracia en
taiwán y en todo el mundo la
determinación de eeuu sigue siendo
fernando
ay
desde 1979 eeuu ha mantenido una línea
ambigua sobre taiwán adoptando la
política de una sola china que reconoce
beijing aún así eeuu mantiene vínculos
no oficiales con taiwán y proporciona a
la isla armas de defensa la presidenta
taiwanesa se mostró desafiante ante la
política de una sola china frente a las
amenazas militares
taiwán no retrocederá defenderemos con
firmeza la soberanía de nuestra nación y
seguiremos manteniendo la línea de
defensa de la democracia la última vez
que un presidente de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu visitó taiwán fue
hace 25 años hoy la atención es mucho
mayor las relaciones entre washington y
beijing se han deteriorado en los
últimos años y ahora china condena los
últimos movimientos como una amenaza
para la paz en la región
eeuu no debería soñar con obstruir la
reunificación de china taiwán es una
parte de china la reunificación completa
de china es una tendencia inevitable de
la historia lo dejaremos espacio a las
fuerzas independentistas de taiwán de
las injerencias externas
5 con quien la visita llegó a beijing a
realizar simulacros aéreos y marítimos
entre taiwán dice que los ejercicios
chinos violan su soberanía
da igual denunció que 27 aviones chinos
sobrevolaron su zona de defensa aérea y
ya esto es un bloqueo algo que el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
china niega según esta cartera los
ejercicios militares tienen el objetivo
de disuadir lo que llamaron acciones
negativas por parte de estados unidos la
cartera añadió que la visita de pelosi
era un feo espectáculo político desde
beijing nuestro corresponsal
adrián foncillas nos amplia
la visita de la congresista nancy pelosi
ha generado un intensísimo tráfico aéreo
en las inmediaciones de taiwán hasta 27
cazas chinos se han adentrado en la zona
de defensa aérea según el ministerio de
defensa taiwanés y 22 de ellos han
llegado más lejos han traspasado la
línea media que sirve de frontera
oficiosa es habitual en tiempos de
tensión que los cazas chinos se adentran
en la zona de defensa aérea pero es
muchísimo más excepcional que traspase
la línea media es el último síntoma de
la indignación supina china por el viaje
de nancy pelosi las rotundas medidas
militares que había anunciado en las
vísperas han cristalizado en unas
masivas maniobras en seis zonas
marítimas que rodean totalmente la isla
los escenarios de algunas maniobras
están dentro de las aguas que taiwán
considera como propias y apenas una
veintena de kilómetros del litoral eso
ha justificado que el ministerio de
defensa taiwanés hoy denunciará lo que
entiende como un bloque de facto tanto
marítimo como aéreo que contraviene la
legislación internacional taipei también
ha denunciado los ataques masivos de
piratas informáticos a la gran mayoría
de sus instituciones públicas y
precisamente estas tensiones entre china
y taiwán serán uno de los temas
principales de la reunión de ministros
de relaciones exteriores de la asean la
asociación de naciones del sudeste
asiático en camboya comenzó la edición
número 55 en donde también hablarán de
la recuperación post pandemia la guerra
en ucrania y el cambio climático una de
las novedades es que los cancilleres de
estados unidos rusia y china- estarán
cara a cara aunque no hay planes de que
los ministros de estas tres potencias en
disputa se reúnan
y otro de los temas más álgidos en la
asean es el golpe de estado en mianmar y
la violencia que se ha desatado desde
que se tomaron el poder los militares en
2021 a pesar de las divisiones que hay
al respecto hoy el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de rusia serguéi
lávrov se reunió con el líder de la
junta de mianmar ming aun line su visita
reafirma la postura de moscú de ver al
ejército de este país asiático como un
aliado mientras que occidente lo ha
sancionado por la opresión hacia los
manifestantes prodemocráticos
y nos vamos a turquía porque ya ha
partido desde el puerto de estambul el
barco cargado con más de 26.000
toneladas de cereales ucranianos que va
a rumbo a trípoli en líbano el buque fue
revisado en territorio turco por un
equipo de inspectores antes de seguir su
viaje por el estrecho del bósforo a
pesar de que es la primera exportación
de granos que ha hecho ucrania ucrania
durante la guerra el presidente de
volodymyr selenski le restó importancia
diciendo que sólo una fracción de la
cosecha nuestro corresponsal en estambul
adrià rocha nos informa
después de pasar la inspección esta
mañana de los inspectores de rusia
ucrania y los mediadores de turquía y
naciones unidas el buque transatlántico
razón y ya está transitando en la ciudad
de estambul y el estrecho del bósforo
con grano y cereales ucranianos que ha
sido el primer barco que sale de ucrania
tras la invasión rusa en febrero de este
año el razón is está transitando el
bósforo en dirección primero al
mediterráneo y después al puerto de
trípoli en el líbano donde podrá
descargar sus 26 mil toneladas de trigo
crearon el primer barco que sale de
ucrania como decíamos desde la invasión
es un tránsito muy importante que
atravesado primero el mar negro llegará
hasta trípoli se espera que dentro de
unos 34 días con su cargo muy importante
decíamos porque es el primero que sale y
se espera que si este tren de tránsito
es seguro y efectivo puedan salir
durante las próximas semanas muchos más
barcos como este desde ucrania destino a
otros países del mundo muy necesitados
de cereales y granos por la grave crisis
alimentaria global por los altos precios
de este producto alimentario
el barco razón y podría no ser el único
buque cargado con granos ucranianos en
llegar al puerto de trípoli el embajador
de ucrania de líbano y ahora estás
afirmó que desde el jueves un buque de
bandera siria atracó en el puerto
libanés con 10.000 toneladas de harina
de trigo y cebada ucranianas que la
firma fueron robadas el diplomático le
pidió al líbano que no permita que el
buque la que el buque la odisea sigue en
sus aguas e instó a las autoridades a
investigar
irán informó que enviará una delegación
a viena para la reanudación de los
diálogos sobre el acuerdo nuclear justo
después del anuncio de teherán un alto
funcionario estadounidense
informó que el delegado de washington
para las conversaciones normal y también
viajará a austria la noticia se conoce
poco después de que la oiea informará
sobre el rápido avance del programa
nuclear iraní teherán negocia con
occidente del restablecimiento del pacto
atómico desde el año pasado y todavía no
hay conclusiones
los principales líderes de los talibanes
de afganistán se reunieron hoy para
discutir cómo responder al ataque con
drones en el que eeuu afirma mató al
líder de al-qaeda ayman al-zawahiri
mientras que washington teme represalias
desde el martes la casa blanca alertó a
sus ciudadanos ante la posibilidad de
nuevos ataques al zawahiri murió el
domingo durante un operativo que se
llevó a cabo en el centro de kabul en
una casa donde el líder se escondía con
su familia es el mayor golpe militar
desde contra al qaeda desde la muerte de
osama vilar
este vídeo compartido por ammar news en
afganistán muestra la zona atacada con
aviones no tripulados estadounidenses
allí murió el jefe de al qaeda ayman
al-zawahiri 11 años después que osama
bin-laden una gran victoria para estados
unidos después del caótico retiro del
gobierno de afganistán el año pasado y
el regreso al poder de los talibanes
ahora se ha hecho justicia y este
terrorista ya no existe dejamos en claro
nuevamente esta noche que no importa
cuánto tiempo tome no importa donde se
escondan si son una amenaza para nuestra
gente eeuu los encontrará y los sacará
el terrorista nacido en egipto y autor
intelectual de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre estaba en el balcón de su
casa cuando fue ejecutado baiden dijo
quien ningún símil murió en el operativo
los talibanes confirmaron previamente
que la casa atacada se encontraba en una
zona de lujo en el centro de kabul
periodistas y medios de comunicación han
identificado la casa y el equipo de
observadores france24 la ha rastreado
hasta este lugar cercano a la embajada
británica funcionarios de inteligencia
aseguraron que obtuvieron información
que zawahiri y su familia se mudaron
este año y lo siguieron durante meses
los talibanes condenaron el ataque y
aseguraron que se violó el acuerdo de
paz de doha de 2020 en el que eeuu
aceptó retirarse por completo de
afganistán en el mismo acuerdo los
talibanes se comprometieron a no ayudar
ni a acoger a grupos terroristas el
departamento de estado de eeuu dice que
los gobernantes afganos estaban al tanto
del cambio de vivienda de zawahiri
el nuevo presidente de sri lanka
ranasinghe
se dirigió al parlamento de su país
donde habló de la crisis económica y de
las conversaciones que reiniciarán en
agosto con el fondo monetario
internacional según el nuevo gobierno
busca reestructurar la deuda externa que
incluye unos 12 mil millones de dólares
adeudados a tenedores de bonos además de
este anuncio dijo que era necesario
introducir enmiendas constitucionales
que buscan restringir los poderes del
presidente una demanda clave que le han
hecho los manifestantes que también
obligaron la salida de gotabaya
rajapaksa
en noticias de américa hay más cambios
en el gabinete de perú el presidente del
consejo de ministros aníbal torres
presentó su renuncia al mandatario pedro
castillo con su salida todos los
ministros deben enviar su dimisión al
presidente este sería su quinto gabinete
en lo que lleva del año nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
nos explicó por qué renuncia a aníbal
torres a nivel torres en su carta de
dimisión le informa al presidente pedro
castillo que su renuncia motivos
personales en realidad torre se siente
cansados del trajín de lo que significa
ser primer ministro de este gobierno en
mayo pasado a nivel torres había
señalado que desde abril había
considerado presentar su carta de
renuncia hay que recordar que se trata
de una persona de 79 años
coincidentemente en las últimas horas y
de acuerdo a los registros de palacio de
gobierno el presidente pedro casi o se
viene reuniendo con ministros
congresistas y algunos abogados cercanos
al oficialismo los incendios en el
hemisferio norte siguen siendo noticia
en california eeuu las llamas causaron
la muerte de cuatro personas y alrededor
de 25.000 hectáreas fueron arrasadas a
medida que el incendio mckinney avanza
por el bosque nacional claman los
bomberos esperan que las lluvias y la
humedad que se prevé en los próximos
días ayuden a controlar las llamas
casas y carros calcinados son casi lo
único que queda de la pequeña ciudad de
klamath el river la mayoría de los
residentes huyeron cuando las llamas
acercaban pero algunas familias
decidieron quedarse como roger de ree y
su hijo
cuando el fuego llegó a ese punto había
llamas de 30 metros a lo largo de unos 8
kilómetros cuando el viento soplaba y
hacía que el incendio bajara como un
soplete sólido no había nada que lo
detuvieran no fue intenso pero es verdad
es muy triste es muy descorazonador
algunas de nuestras casas más antiguas
casas de 100 años han desaparecido
con el tiempo se reconstruirá pero va a
llevar algún tiempo estamos realmente
devastado la ryder de sede
mckinney comenzó pocos días después de
que otro incendio oak amenazar el parque
nacional de yosemite
provocando la evacuación de miles de
personas
es el mayor incendio forestal en el
estado en lo que va del año y las
autoridades están instando a la gente a
evacuar las zonas amenazadas por el
fuego
siempre que haya alerta de evacuación
creo que la gente debería seguir ese
consejo y evacuar esas zonas vimos un
comportamiento intenso del fuego de
viernes a domingo así que si le piden
que evacúen siga el consejo aún quedan
varios meses de intenso calor y sequedad
en california por lo que la temporada de
incendios está en su punto álgido
y hasta aquí llega a este informativo
los invitamos a que sigan con france24
[Música]